what is up there citizens of the reject Nation
we're gonna watch the final episode of this
season of black mirror today I want to thank
everyone who has been on this journey with
us we thought the show would be bigger yes
not but hey for those who have decided to
stick around with us we appreciate you that
much more John how's it going I am great I'm
ready for whatever this is about to be how
are you I'm doing well Johnny Boy ladies gentlemen
leave a like hold a mirror up to yourself
and see that you are holding a like button
also full-length Reaction watch along where
you sing with their own copy of Black Mirror
available for our super sexy rejects over
at our patreon page thank you to everyone
who has joined just for this show alone we've
actually gotten a lot of patrons just due
to this one Series so thank you very much
we also cover many things over there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included so this show is big enough alrighty
guys let's swing into action
[Music]
hell yes definitely in the 70s I've never
seen such 4K film grain before yeah digitally
rendered to perfectly emulate the look of
film [Music]
[Music] cinematography and Framing and these
zooms are certainly doing the trick somehow
already invested in her day I like getting
to know a character just through images
[Music] that's Perfection right there you
could be that got a customer I'm on my lunch
yeah I can smell that mine's in five minutes
so if I start with a customer now it cuts
into my break so come off yours that's Keith
holigan sir he murdered his wife oh it was
manslaughter
surely we don't have to serve him everyone
needs shoes neither how about doing your job
go help the nice manslaughterer I think I'm
going to need the 11. I'm large from a height
yeah look at this is it I wonder if that was
a character Choice sure you can't do a discount
I'm so sorry no we can I'm just a bit strapped
till the end of the month I can put them aside
for you if you fancy writing down your number
I won't mind oh yeah do it
[Music]
yeah it's a nice like cheeky editing the donation
has suffered through a winter of discontent
now they promised us a brighter future labor
isn't working
Michael's smart you're gonna have to look
around to see it rubbish in the streets crime
on the
on the threat excellent I refuse to think
this has anything to do with her race
foreign
[Applause] [Music] as the election near polisher
Mrs Thatcher's conservative party retains
a commanding need you're going to bring your
visualizations to life
Russia long ago he was big and strong and
his eyes are faming low
I
really don't make him like that anymore I
understand you're in the habits of eating
your lunch in the stockroom we don't mind
but it's it's what you're eating oh God you
see most people's food um normal food it doesn't
tend to linger afterwards oh my so if you
must eat in there maybe just bring in a sandwich
like a chick like a cheese and ham sandwich
or just a cheese sandwich you know if you're
one of those that doesn't do happen oh my
yes
yes I did bring the Biryani in today well
eat in the street yes find an alleyway how
about the basement even better
murder yeah you want to do it go ahead beat
her head and do something yes
nice
hello what you want
cool
let's bring some of these mannequins to life
make them do your bidding be like that Doctor
Who episode
so the man who used to work here left paper
clip cutouts of his allegations yeah of his
entire life story
oh is she looking at the string get that string
Oh I thought she was looking at the pick oh
I was joking it's pretty obvious for sure
red herring you Bond it to it now
yep
it's disconcerting with the mannequins yeah
well done show well done [Music]
whoa it's sweet it's like an evil totem uh
yeah all right so my name's Dart I'm a demon
you're known this tattoosman with your blood
so now we're back together crush it now and
so I'll be over oh man don't embrace your
Darkness you were not into Talisman and the
rules are you've got to carry out free human
sacrifices over the next three days or else
the world's gonna win if you want me to help
you you need to permit me entry cool you'll
never hear from me again like this didn't
happen just say yes say it say it come on
say it say it say it say it say it is the
kind of notes I would pass in school you said
yes way too fast too much of a pushover oh
no crew and extra lines
foreign
apparently this is a physical look you find
a feeling so hell yes it's Blood and Bone
you know you marked the Talisman I don't make
the rules I mean basically we need to deliver
free sacrifices by Mammoth I was burning Skies
time all right let it burn I think she needs
some convincing uh let me show you how this
will play out three two one whoa
my apartment's gonna burn down and I don't
have it insured for disasters [Applause] [Music]
Nate
[Applause]
some really weird editing yeah and to be honest
I don't want the apocalypse to come about
any more than you do so let's stop it happening
you and me all you have to do is deliver free
days it's really well edited yeah that is
fewer people desire falling off ladders in
the same time period you'd be less lethal
than a ladder
under your belt stop racking them up killing
anyone you actually think of these two people
you want to kill three oh yeah well support
so just hold on to that break let's go flag
someone brick in your hand love
are you all right I Need a Doctor you want
me to go and call one this guy's horrible
helping out the city oh my name's Laura she's
eight years old
the bastard makes her feel get load of this
oh he could be making all this up still true
yeah she kills herself age 28 exhausted by
the pain and the shame of it
okay okay
oh that poor dog has no idea what's happening
good thing you waited till you got back to
throw up a couple more throws and I'll be
out of your head see one line gone that's
one sacrifice registered two to go pick the
next one so very practical person boy or girl
uh man it's okay Laura this lady are going
to help find daddy she doesn't want that
oh
you're late for work you're gonna have to
go in you know you can't have people getting
suspicious I mean if you don't turn off you
should talk
but this time they'll be right they'll be
totally bloody right you're not crazy I'm
a murderer you're being a crazy one
perfectly sane logical murderer I'm not a
bad person I don't know it wouldn't work if
you are it has to be someone corruptable
oh Jesus calling the police what why I know
I know okay you don't want the brother three
sacrificial victims on your hands but if it
saves billions trolley problem why would the
demon care to save everyone though carry on
as usual so the normals don't get spooked
which means going to work we can decide who
to kill next yeah make that decision real
quick I don't care what anyone says this is
to be my favorite episode yeah
a lot of fun
run off the algae I think No actually that's
still from the till you know she's steals
from the two she can't stop thinking about
the end though they can't wait for it to come
you'd be you'd be doing her a favor what was
that [Music]
turned a buzzy yeah but he's dead
wow someone's clobbered him sir it's clobbering
time oh nice what time do you finish depends
what time you want to start huh right now
I won't want to stop here
do you want the apocalypse open you're in
the way I love this plot it's so simple oh
geez so rich yeah
you know no you're not you're not a nice person
way too grabby got your hands all out
that's you you're a Basher that's courage
hey I don't drink yeah [__] yeah we're
going out but do you want a drink let's go
I choose to believe the demon is real but
I like them uh infused in the real world of
war tensions yeah because that it makes you
question whether or not it's real there's
all just in her head all sorts of plausible
explanations yeah triple Scotch please there
you see he's still got work today
actually make it two triple scotches thank
you I don't have to get one for me I didn't
uh oh he's gonna be begging her to stop by
the end of this
three years ago before his wife was cheating
oh hell yeah Keith Johnny wasn't premeditated
but he did have a hard on when he did it so
oh should Grace you embrace it
hit me chug
he's following me from Bob you're a dog also
yeah I've read about girls like you oh sure
you have I'm just round corner you know what
aren't Earth even better I watch sense him
being shy now it's still dangerous for her
though sure he could overpower her oh yeah
what are the what's good demons gonna do if
she actually gets killed right now so it's
midnight you're cutting it fine okay what
was that can't wait to [__] you
ah
a
tell you what you you get comfy I'll just
go and have a wash down there first
it is 11 54. six minutes left since you asked
and from behind oh dude come on
you're gonna hit me with that I always knew
something would happen oh ever since I did
it oh wow well I deserve I can honestly did
a little bit at least I'm editing one's the
demons some credibility too just egg around
man and Hell
knew this guy didn't live alone oh geez get
that third one in early that has to be one
a day but if it's like two minutes to midnight
now she get us 1201.
okay no no eyewitnesses
please
oh golly
that's so awkward yes it's real throw it at
his head oh boy
[Music]
is kill gonna count get it password Maybe
there we go oh you are a stabber
I wonder if it's gonna fall on a technicality
would not be surprised
oh oh let's give it another stab yeah enjoy
it just come on go ahead and enjoy it check
the time counts I'm gonna go back and check
the time and that's he's gonna do tonight
our one today is just the minimum but two
it doesn't get you over the line get down
there oh so it does count see it um I guess
no yeah nope he's wrong
Circle 1926 uh but the room face has failed
to register one of the sacrifices I mean yeah
but well we
didn't can why he's a murderer but we've been
picking people who deserve it I mean it was
strictly supposed to do it that way I just
I thought you'd find it easier oh my God but
basically anyone that has already been directly
responsible for the death of another human
being they're off limits oh good thing she
got two tonight then I failed my initiation
I kicked out of demons called boo who cast
out into a boundless Cosmic void better than
apocalypse infinite nothingness absence of
matter of time space light and sand this poor
demon alone in perpetuity forevermore wow
comfort him but through a hard time
she's made as we have to avoid you mean people
like me a whole life I never wished harm on
anyone yeah okay I mean you can summon me
from my trial if you hadn't pissed you off
there we go might as well here's Nida stop
that you can deal with a kid out there needs
black shoes for a few they pulled his heart
look now ah you spared her another five years
of it a lifetime of therapy but a lifetime
nonetheless I believe in therapy well Scientology
says it's the tools of the devil so of course
I insist too late here we are oh he kills
mayor let's get all three well I said I'd
leave you in hands of our finest assistant
so um Vicky she could take care of Michael
Michael oh my God just kill the whole store
just bludgeoned them all with shoes so wait
till he comes out reverse into him up against
the wall keep the pedal down to your head
a stomach pop
National front for me don't like how things
are changing around here oh my God you know
what I don't Prince stop immigrate regress
is on my campaign because look at me looks
like Thomas Jane
you know what I stand for somebody glamored
her to have your vote yes sir good girl oh
you devil you haven't got long what's his
future Michael smart uh can you show me his
future I love this 16 417. that's not just
different they're in theory they're even expelled
from the Tories Michael smart launched his
new the rivers of blood are here yes Victory
Britain has a new prime minister what's coming
Rising seats wow
why not kill this guy is not one of us not
literally
technically yeah can I choose Michael smart
he's the one in that well honestly they are
not gonna like it but it's within the rules
that they can lump at yes go oh he's created
someone he wants to try an 11. hurry up it's
gone Closing Time Still's there do it yourself
yeah
let me harder to spot blood on that thing
too
[Music] you've changed
that'll be the hot new fashion next week all
right winning last night he's in most nights
anything unusual about him well he killed
his wife
sat on his purse dragging his pants up left
around Closing Time anyone follow him over
well that's all oh no the other bartender
Lady it's Indian loss never been in before
drunk two triple scotches by yourself can
you describe her yeah Indian hey is that over
there sorry talking to herself Works in shoes
at posits did they yeah I thought that was
her face do you mind if I have a word yeah
sure inside environment and then kill him
you're in the pub last night the three crowns
to be honest last night was the first time
just around the corner isn't it well I don't
drink not usually yesterday was Mom's birthday
well done yeah oligan's Heath and Chris I've
not heard of them I'm afraid looks like you
served him at work a few days ago oh we get
so many in the door to be honest by the end
of the day I hardly recognize myself
so you didn't see him I certainly didn't notice
him so sorry it wasn't more helpful
I'm impressed he didn't boiler that's hurry
then smart will be finishing his speech
are you getting followed yeah I'm gonna have
a back door or something this election may
decide Our Fate will that fate his eyes to
decide so don't just hope for a better future
vote for one
get him got a bad feeling about this
[Applause] [Music]
I am driving gloves so fancy oh that'd be
so perfect just push him into the train I
know oh Lord [Music] Italian Job perfect
you're an officer of the law just get out
and badge the train man I want her to get
away with it you know it's not too late to
just find someone else shut up I'm just saying
it would be much easier for me if you just
find someone else's you're not gonna help
them piss off fine
I mean if she's gonna do it she wants to feel
Justified and that she's providing Justice
I wonder if she's just gonna drive right into
him maybe she doesn't want to live through
this
foreign
yes
wow [Music] make sure the job the deed is
done before the cop gets there hurry run run
won't help me then
[Music] hurry stop milking it yeah
[Music] I have to do it
you know if I don't do this by midnight that'll
be wrong we'll deal with if it comes to it
oh sorry
okay
we're so close each time you sacrifice someone
it got registered on the Talisman is that
right this is a Talisman yeah no it's called
normal now before was it chest in her head
the demon who told you to do all this and
what did he look like like a monster at first
then he turned into the man from born again
oh no
tell her why he did that it'll make more sense
Insanity plea
my mother feels sorry for her no matter how
much sympathy mine must have for a personal
situation it's from this morning oh hell yeah
yeah
[Music] yes burn it all where you at gab you're
already off in the void just got word they
are casting me out and eternal Oblivion so
sorry if you want to come with me oh that
means nice they don't say anything about a
human companion into Eternal Oblivion I know
it's much less than that it's with me [Music]
true damnation okay cool
oh [Music]
[Music] I bet you feel really bad now huh
yeah sure let that man die
oh wow
[Music] that's awesome
[Music] how sweet I love this
Toby Haynes I know that name
I don't hear anyone really talk about that
episode but I loved it yeah I think that's
my favorite one I don't think I know for sure
that's 100 my favorite one and that has the
least to do with technology yeah what is that
there's a receipt machine that they used to
track her link to that one guy they just went
completely Supernatural with that one yeah
or the technology of nuclear war and all that
which is a technological advancement sure
uh but it's a cool old history take that was
fun that was great I loved it I loved it so
much I love such a simple premise that is
all about the nuance and the relationships
and watch Finding this optimistic ending at
the end for because it's like the whole world
gets doomed but I'm so aware we're living
in an alternate reality with this show that
I'm like yeah I'm down burn the world don't
care burn it all down I just want to see her
be happy yeah and then at the end they get
it and they have incredible chemistry those
two just the the perform and they both get
an arc I could not believe what I was watching
that was so well done yeah I I could give
a [__] if people don't like it that was
awesome no that was that was that was really
awesome with some awesome stylist flourishes
throughout 45 second opinion done John would
you think yeah no I love the way this snaked
through tones and really just relished in
the question mark of its you know whole Central
premise like you know you start out with what
clearly feels like okay we're homage and some
kind of paranoid 70s satanic movie but I thought
their subversions to and twists on that tone
it worked nicely to establish something that
embodied both the twisted humor and the foreboding
you know uh doomishness that Black Mirror
can often come with but in a totally other
way and yeah like to have the central relationship
that starts out in such a you know with such
you know opposition and tension that then
you know goes through all these shifts and
power changes until the point where they're
finally both at the end and resigned and and
it becomes this sort of Twisted Little Love
Story uh yeah that was was beautiful and and
like you know this season has been in some
ways more Fantastical thus far but uh I like
what they've been doing with those Fantastical
elements and yeah something like this I think
plays nicely because it's something you'll
hear echoed like oh you know this person who
killed such and such amount of people like
was convinced of you know some kind of Apocalypse
scenario or some you know message from a higher
or lower power and yeah I thought there's
their trade from her living in the oblivions
of life to them living together in the oblivions
of the afterlife like Eternal damnation but
also like you know getting off kind of easy
away from the rest of the world yeah so is
like so sweet while also being really harsh
and nasty and and you know stomach churning
at points the way again I think Black Mirror
does um and two I think you know while it's
while they're not necessarily always leading
with like you know the commentary this season
I still think that there are like this episode
is a lot of nice and and interesting and harsh
flourishes of you know just the political
Spectrum Circa you know the 70s and the Cold
War and things like that but also things that
are certainly relevant to the here and now
like as much as it feels removed from now
it also doesn't you know
um no I I don't think it feels I don't think
it feels removed at all and especially with
with the the person running for mayor was
his whole diabolical plan and his big end
game going down the road they interspice it
with footage that looked modern day and then
footage that looked futuristic at the same
time of what the kind of political Wars they
would ultimately land into due to this one
guy and that once he once he lived I was like
okay this is God they did have they did have
me fold for a hot minute it was it was when
the clock turned midnight and then nothing
happened which was gonna bum me out I wanted
it to be real I wanted everything to end I
wanted the world to incinerate yeah so when
they come around to that I was I was relieved
but I had an inkling that because he lived
I was like okay yeah this has to be this has
to be real but I do like that it plays on
the whole thing of um like a joker or even
uh what was that Scientology riff movie that
Paul Thomas Anderson did no the master yeah
kind of like the master both Joaquin Phoenix
performances but also a bit of like Henry
portrait of a serial killer this innocent
timid but not enter Portugal it was not that
but the the archetype of a innocent timid
character who arcs into embracing her own
inner demons and then finds confidence within
herself by the end of the journey uh I think
is it was a great character Arc that I found
very believable and every little moment of
her seem that like you knew where the trajectory
of her performance was headed it could have
gone down a path where she just becomes completely
sadistic and just really wants to kill and
become a badass he becomes a badass or becomes
very diabolical it could have gone down a
whole number of paths that went to a further
extreme but they managed to even though she
murdered they managed to maintain her humanity
and a moral compass within that while letting
that Darkness also live on the surface as
well so they kept it in this complex gray
area that I was really impressed by what they
landed her with because I thought they might
have they might have landed her on a much
darker spot as I liked how she was even pushing
away uh Gap got huh Gap I think Gap uh I like
how she kept pushing GOP away as she wanted
to murder this guy and he even had to be on
his own and he wasn't even feeling rejected
I loved his performance of how he was just
the new guy in this Demon World and was just
trying to prove himself so he had it like
this charming affable quality to him who tried
to oversimplify things and didn't oh didn't
push his desperation to get this done too
much like he just tried keeping it light-hearted
the whole time it was refreshing it was this
kind of dynamic I feel like I've seen in other
B movie horror films not exactly you know
specific one to one but normally they would
go for a little bit more of a dread heavy
and make that guy a lot more serious and stoic
and maybe just like sinisterly charming and
they didn't do any of that they flipped everything
on its head yeah and they even had this Con
I never really thought about it because um
I i s the first time I ever really understood
that there was a large Indian population in
Britain was when we saw Bennett Like Beckham
and so I wasn't really attuned to anything
historical or present at all going on break
again I was like we're like [__] like
10 or 11 or something so I didn't really know
anything and that was when I first became
a tune to it and I didn't ever really factor
in what the racism experience and oppression
must have felt like for them and and so they
had all these neat ingredients in this little
Boiling Pot recipe to make you go there's
a lot of justifications of how she could have
just gotten pushed to a Breaking Point and
just blaming on them they even set up this
little tease about my they thought my mom
was crazy but I'm actually crazy uh it was
it was smart it was really really smart I
think even though they don't leave with commentary
more most of the time they they still leave
with the character and they did an excellent
job here uh and and use its aesthetic and
backdrop of 70s uh horror exploitation ish
Vibes uh I thought it was just going to be
gimmicky at the beginning and then it made
me forget about all that the second the demon
speaks for the first time I was like okay
like you know you're either gonna lose me
or not and and I think you know as I think
something like that you know you think of
demons as one thing and so the easy undercut
is to have him you know talk Cockney and and
you know like anybody else but I thought that
they actually managed to like I love the tunes
of his performance because he really towed
a nicely sort of murky line between charm
and manipulation and that I think fuels so
much of the the question mark again of you
know is this real is this not real is he just
trying to egg her on to you know corrupt her
spirit and all that talk about you needed
to be a corruptable person not Beyond corruption
and not already completely corrupted and touching
on things that are sort of latent you know
it's like she has those fantasies about you
know bashing her co-workers head in or the
you know the you know manager of their shoe
department or whatever um and you know acknowledging
that that exists within and yeah going so
far as to find where it fits almost within
her personality or how she might look if she
embraced it without yeah just going full-on
absurd like just like the fantasy you know
like violent rage and then doing like Gore
for the sake of Gore like I thought this episode
managed to have like the the kind of shocking
Thrills and the sort of grindhouse flourishes
that you would like but also it never got
lost in just having too much fun with those
things and and like yeah that whole bit between
the politician and the the other girl you
know the the crappy uh you know super mean
shoes shoe sales girl or whatever like that
whole thing where he's just explaining to
her that like yeah like the system only works
in this one particular way sort of and I'm
gonna take those values and I'm gonna snake
them my way into you know my best chance of
actually winning of gaming the system and
I just thought it was funny that they made
so much out of that character and whether
or not you could take him out and kill him
and I love that that morality play turns into
like a true sort of inversion because yeah
it's like she could just kill her co-workers
She Could Just Kill the manager but you know
like it's like how can I take this curse and
make it as like effective in a positive way
as I can or at least use it to remove that
much more suffering like how can I make this
trolley problem work for me and I thought
that was a great scene because it is like
something that you could easily kind of lose
to the strangeness of the moment but uh but
yeah then it's like you have this actual demon
this guy who's actually in a very physical
Way Towing that murky line of charm and manipulation
but in like an overtly evil way whereas like
yeah the the demon it does kind of pose like
a fun sort of question mark as well about
yeah who's the lesser of the evils here and
whatnot um but yeah yeah just like their interactions
back and forth and the the changing of their
Dynamics just every beat was so lovely and
uh yeah their their Harmony and watching as
they trade kind of in who's doing more of
the talking and the having more of the confidence
is just so gradual and nicely handled yeah
and I love the cop too the the cop was very
sympathetic empathetic and you could feel
this
is you feel the experience in the most simplistic
terms I would say uh you can feel this the
horrors this guy has witnessed and obviously
is the one one of the few who's not racist
in the characters that we follow and I love
the Nuance to his performance of he yeah he's
got to catch the Killer but there's this part
of him that can understand even without knowing
much he can connect with her in a in an unspoken
manner just find bits of information and conclude
a possible history as to why this person is
the way they are and what might even lead
this person to do what they do the way I was
very effective and he starts off as like a
guy who doesn't really give a [__] to
an individual who gives the motions and I
thought that was I thought that was really
well executed I think I think they inhabited
this world really well that I think each each
episode here presented um a fervent eye to
it all I thought it was a lot of passion on
display from beginning to end though the one
that had the most just fun I think like stream
Berry well I think is the most talked about
one um it's the most on that's actually my
least favorite the first one was actually
my least favorite of them all um and and then
I would probably go with Beyond the Sea I
would go I don't know I would say that in
order for favorites I'll go this one Beyond
the Sea lock Henry yeah amazing day amazing
day and then John is awful and then Joan is
awful yeah that would be my ranking my personal
ranking of them all uh I think that these
I thought it was a great season and yeah each
episode left truly left an impression on me
um yeah and I think just looking at the whole
thing even though it's an anthology I thought
the different lengths I thought each episode
was proportioned well unto itself and a lot
of people have slagged off uh Maisie day especially
for being like yeah short and like the least
deep but even that one I thought like nicely
inhabited what it was supposed to be and for
a season like this with a couple feature-length
episodes I'm like yeah do one lean and mean
do one that's like an actual you know dramatic
feature and then yeah do something like this
that is like both fun and filled with abandon
but also you know focused and graceful in
surprising and unexpected ways and and yeah
like for a season again that seems like it's
wanted to train uh change some things or at
least try some new flavors out I thought that
was a successful experiment kind of across
the board and I thought that a lot of the
principles I have kind of just been taking
from these changes have been sort of well
embodied by this episode across the board
in particular
well guys what'd you think about Black Mirror
what would be your favorite of the five leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like thank you for everyone who joined
us on this journey but before we go let's
end this with a patreon Lex I think you would
make a good Demon and I would listen to all
of your input and advices and uh you know
I I like to think that I'm a relatively you
know morally inclined person but if anybody
could corrupt me I imagine that it would be
you all right your persuasive you you're friendly
but uh who knows what you could be thinking
and what you could be latently influencing
me to do and uh and I like you know not to
have uh too much culpability for my own circumstances
and decisions so if I could just Pawn all
that stuff onto you and you know I know you'll
have my back you know if I'm ever caught or
anything like that so I think this could be
the start of a beautiful friendship beautiful
working relationship so uh yeah I'm just putting
that out into the universe take some my blood
and let's make a pact uh that you know you'll
staple that'll be the things like you'll stay
pledged but for your pledge money I'll sacrifice
anybody you want and that's a fact Jack you
can take that to the bank we love you my dear
and stay well we'll talk soon [Music]